action action action
we're here in raja ampat a group of
islands off of
west papua it's quite remote it's very
very beautiful
above water as well as underwater
the challenges faced in terms of
filmmaking
are quite extreme and we added to that
by bringing along
a beast of a camera the quality of the
imax 1570 format is the highest quality
bar none the problem that we've had
shooting with the solido camera and
moving it around and the complications
of filming in a third world country like
this
is some of these locations that we want
to work in
are really arduous going through jungle
trails
muddy swamps mangrove swamps rickety
foot bridges
all the while carrying along a 250 pound
camera that's the size of a small
refrigerator
and takes four people just to move it a
couple feet
and our job as the filmmakers is to
try to capture pretty interesting places
in a way
that allows the audience to feel like
they are there
and imax is the only format that can do
that
filming with the imax camera is a little
bit more challenging the imax camera
camera's very big it's
250 pounds in the underwater housing and
it only runs for three minutes before we
have to change film
another thing that we're faced with is
in this part of the world you have your
wet season and your dry season but
there's always rain
there's always clouds there's always
humidity
neal are you all wet a little bit
and i don't know that i've ever been in
a place where the weather
changes so fast
one of the aspects of our shooting is
aerial photography it's a very important
part of every film that we make
i'm the aerial cinematographer so my job
is to go out to these amazing places
like wyag
and shoot the most amazing scenery that
i've ever seen so this is a space cam
with the imax
camera fitted in it's a beautiful rig
it's it's 15 perf
65 millimeter film
the biggest challenge here is distance
to location and places to land
we had a problem we were going to have
to base the helicopter out of the town
of sarong
which was quite a few miles away because
there's nowhere to land a helicopter
here these are
rugged jungle islands so we said to the
villages do you know of any place that's
an open space where we can land the
helicopter and they said no
but we can make an open space for you
it's been quite amazing when we ask the
villagers
to do things in a matter of minutes
often it's accomplished and it's really
been
remarkable
at the end of the day you you may have
faced some
extreme frustrations but it's a real
sense of accomplishment king of the
world
it kind of feeds your passion for what
you do here
but it isn't all about how hard it is
it's all about
the shots we get in the stories we tell
and when the audience
member sits down in a seat in the
theater they don't really care how hard
it was they just want to be
taken from that seat and brought into
the experience
nice